oh so you brought up South Carolina
after the word the next primary is and I
was very interested to see that your for
Jeb Bush right yes ma'am he brought out
his brother George W Bush apparently he
thinks he can be very influential with
with the key Republican demographic
ninety percent approval rating in South
Carolina and this is what I want to get
at because South Carolina a lot of
veterans a lot of military people who
love george w bush
do you remember what jeb bush's big
gaffe was at the beginning of the
campaign they asked him about if you
know what we know now if you know today
what we knew then would you go into iraq
and he said yes all the other Republican
candidates jumped on him Ted Cruz said
knowing what we know now of course we
wouldn't get into Iraq how could you be
so stupid as to be cheerleading for a
war that I was for only two years ago
okay but they all said the same thing
basically Trump brags all the time about
he's the only one who was against the
war in Iraq so okay we all agree that
the war in Iraq was a mistake shouldn't
george w bush be the least popular guy
among the military
it's like battered wife syndrome why do
you like a guy who sent you to lose
lives and limbs and be away from your
family to a war we now agree was not
necessarily you know he's also we've
also so
I think there are few former precedents
that have done as much for veterans for
wounded warriors as Georgia but they
wouldn't even do well you know what
if you have leadership abilities
leadership yes leadership abilities yeah
well I guess I watch a lot of
velocity TV at home looking at how to
work on cars and whatnot and there's one
commercial that comes on in disgusts me
every time it comes on my heart goes
with the soldier he's on it and he's
shaking throughout the entire commercial
they showed you and they give you a
pitch of a Wounded Warrior syndrome and
I say the exact same thing you said why
don't we stop sending poor and
working-class boys to war and then we
don't have to have those commercials we
don't have to have a charity we don't
have to get angry that the VA hospital
won't see them for post-traumatic stress
syndrome when they come back so we have
higher suicide rates if we do the right
thing by avoiding war we don't have to
have that
no photo please I mean I think he's I
think George W Bush is a war criminal
you know he sent all of these people to
die and some of them came back and Eddie
is not thrown a charm around so loosely
I mean I'm not a comedian and everything
but you know what kernels are not secure
a box and hasn't showed up at the last
two Republican conventions okay a lot of
people do feel that way and only maybe
in the insular community of the South
Carolina Republican Party does he have
some oh I don't think Jeb would have him
out on the campaign trail if he weren't
in some real trouble electorally well
think about this you know where does
where does Hillary Clinton bring out a
bill where he can actually help so you
know think about a politician actually
being strategic as to where they use
their assets and their resources well I
don't think he's much of an asset or a
resource well the people of South
Carolina disagree let's let's let him
vote and then we'll right if
they disagree I'm not sure his approval
numbers and I think South Carolina are
through the roof I'm not convinced yet
that he's gonna be an asset for jail do
you disagree no his approval numbers in
South Carolina amongst Republicans are
through the roof I don't trust polls
anything Oh laughter what we see looks
like did you say something in a
respectful way but as a comedian I don't
exactly agree with what she said either
but we comedians hate it when we make a
serious point and somebody says you're a
comedian okay okay because yes we're
comedians and we also could make good
point okay all right I'm just telling
you I want it I want to tell you
lived through civil war in Nicaragua and
fled war in the corral fled communism
when you flow around a term like war
criminal right it is personal to me but
just okay and comedians personal to us
okay so things are funnier than others
but it's not funny I'm just I'm talking
about all the people who came back from
a war that we shouldn't have gone to
because of George Bush yeah that's why I
think he's working it okay Margaret you
think he's a war criminal you know I
think he was commander-in-chief I think
he's got to live with some of his you
know mistakes I think he does and you
know I think he also showed great
leadership qualities we did not get
another 9/11 under here he was able to
pull this country together way that we
have a movie this really okay this
bothers me too this is a this is
something Jeb always says you know my
brother kept us safe I remember that one
day he did not and this selective memory
that we have about is somehow that the
terrorism started the day after 9/11 we
remember this there was memos coming in
all the time that supposedly were read
to him Osama bin Laden is standing right
behind you
bill and there's you know there's people
who lost loved ones in st. Bernard II
know that feel exactly the same way
about President Obama so we can you
really think President Obama could have
done anything to stop San Bernardino me
what Obama should have done to stop San
Bernardino you just do you think we have
the fish intelligence capacities that we
did before well if we don't it's because
Congress voted them differently and yes
we have incredible intelligence
capabilities and that would not have
stopped the San Bernardino killers they
still have not been able to open their
phone